Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
de la transmission du COVID,
notamment via d’un article publié ce mois-ci
par deux physiciens du MIT aux États-Unis.
A première vue vous vous demandez peut-être
ce que des physiciens viennent faire
dans cette histoire,
le COVID c’est quand même avant tout
un problème de virologie, de médecine.
Eh bien c’est parce qu’on va parler de
la transmission du COVID par voie aérienne,
une forme de transmission
dont vous allez voir
qu’elle repose assez largement sur
des principes physiques.
Et l’objectif de l’article
dont je vais vous parler,
c’est de voir comment limiter au mieux
ce mode de transmission.
[jingle]
A l’heure actuelle, on distingue
essentiellement
3 modes de transmission du Sars-Cov-2,
le virus responsable du COVID.
Il y a tout d’abord le mode qu’on pourrait
appeler « grosses gouttelettes ».
L’idée est connue: quand on tousse, qu’on
éternue ou qu’on postillonne,
on va projeter des gouttelettes
qui contiennent du virus.
Si ces gouttelettes atterrissent dans
la bouche, le nez ou les yeux
d’une autre personne, on est susceptible
de la contaminer.
On sait que ces gouttelettes ont des tailles
qui peuvent atteindre le millimètre,
et comme elles sont relativement grosses
elles vont tomber sous l’effet de la gravité.
On estime donc sur la base de diverses
visualisations
que ces gouttelettes vont être projetées
au maximum à environ 2m.
C’est la raison pour laquelle on recommande
généralement
cette distance minimale comme geste barrière.
Et c’est aussi bien sûr une motivation
importante pour le port du masque
qui permet de bloquer le jet
des gouttelettes.
Autre mode de contamination possible: via
les surfaces.
Si des gouttelettes atterrissent par exemple
sur une table
que je viens ensuite toucher, je vais ramener
du virus sur mes mains,
et si je les porte à ma bouche, à mon nez
ou mes yeux, je vais me contaminer.
Le geste barrière pour ce mode
de contamination
on le connait: se laver régulièrement
les mains au savon,
utiliser du gel hydroalcoolique
si on n’a pas mieux,
et désinfecter les surfaces susceptibles
d’être contaminées.
Ce mode de transmission par les surfaces,
qui avait été envisagé très tôt,
on pense aujourd’hui qu’il n’est certainement
pas un mode très actif,
on manque de preuves directes qu’il agisse
de façon vraiment significative.
En revanche avec l’évolution de notre
compréhension des mécanismes,
on pense maintenant qu’un mode
de transmission majeur voire dominant,
c’est la transmission par voie aérienne,
par les aérosols.
Je vous ai parlé des grosses gouttelettes,
mais il n’y a pas qu’elles.
Quand on tousse, mais aussi quand on parle
et même simplement par notre respiration,
nous émettons tout un ensemble
de gouttelettes beaucoup plus petites,
dont la taille peut aller d’une centaine
de microns à moins d’un micron.
Ces gouttelettes proviennent de notre salive,
et des muqueuses des poumons et des voies
respiratoires,
et même si vous n’avez pas de symptômes
comme la toux ou les éternuements,
vous allez naturellement émettre
ces gouttelettes.
Or contrairement aux grosses gouttelettes
dont on a parlé juste avant,
celles-ci peuvent, si elles sont
suffisamment petites,
rester en suspension dans l’air.
Les mouvements d’air ambiants sont suffisants
pour compenser leur chute
sous l’effet de la gravité.
Pour ces micro-gouttelettes en suspension
dans l’air, on utilise le terme d’aérosols,
et ces aérosols en suspension peuvent
diffuser librement dans une pièce close,
et venir contaminer une personne,
même si elle se situe
à plus que deux mètres du porteur du virus.
Il n’existe évidemment pas de frontière
stricte
entre les grosses gouttelettes
dont on a parlé, et les aérosols.
Plus les gouttelettes sont grosses,
plus elles vont tomber rapidement au sol,
plus elles sont petites, plus elles sont
susceptibles de rester en suspension.
Depuis maintenant plusieurs mois,
les preuves s’accumulent
quant à l’importance de ce mode
de contamination,
qui avait été initialement sous-estimé.
Un récent article publié dans "The Lancet"
a d’ailleurs fait le point
sur les nombreux arguments qui supportent
cette thèse.
Parmi eux, on peut notamment citer
les événements de super contamination,
ou une seule personne malade a pu
en infecter des dizaines d’autres.
On peut penser à ce trajet en car en Chine,
ou 1/3 des passagers ont été testés positifs,
pour un trajet qui n’a duré que 2h30.
Ou encore à cette chorale aux États-Unis
dans l’état de Washington,
où 53 personnes sur 61 ont été infectées
en une seule soirée de répétition.
Pour expliquer ces événements
de super contamination,
la proximité physique ne suffit pas,
et l’on doit envisager
un mode de contamination à longue distance,
comme la transmission par les aérosols.
Je vous ai dit au début de la vidéo qu’on
allait se pencher
sur l’analyse de cette question
faite par deux physiciens.
Ce qu’ils expliquent dans leur article,
c’est qu’en intérieur,
dans une pièce close, la diffusion
à l’ensemble de la pièce
d’aérosols contaminés peut être
assez rapide.
Les mouvements naturels de l’air,
les déplacements des personnes,
font qu’après quelques dizaines
de minutes au maximum,
on peut presque considérer la concentration
d’aérosols
comme homogène partout dans la pièce.
Cela voudrait dire que pour ce mode
de contamination, la distance importe peu.
Que vous soyez assez proche du porteur
ou à l’autre bout de la pièce,
le risque sera similaire.
Dans ces conditions, qu’est-ce
qu’on peut faire?
L’idée de l’article dont on va parler
était de fournir
une analyse quantitative du phénomène,
afin d’avoir des guides
sur l’attitude à adopter.
Le but étant de limiter de façon raisonnable
ce mode de transmission du virus,
en jouant par exemple sur le nombre
de personnes présentes,
le temps passé en espace clos, ou encore
la quantité d’aération à fournir.
Pour vous expliquer l’analyse faite
dans l’article,
je vais prendre un cas concret
qui devrait vous parler.
Imaginons une classe de collégiens,
dont un des élèves est porteur
sans le savoir.
Qu’il soit peu symptomatique, ou bien qu’il
n’ait pas encore été diagnostiqué,
on peut imaginer qu’il va rester quelques
jours en cours, en étant contagieux.
Question: combien de camarades va-t-il
contaminer dans sa salle de classe,
et comment faire pour que ce soit
si possible 0?
Pour répondre à cette question, on va faire
quelques petits calculs
à partir de principes physiques simples.
Il va y avoir quelques formules, mais
je vais aussi essayer
de vous faire sentir les ordres de grandeur
importants.
La première chose à savoir, c’est que
du fait de sa simple respiration,
notre élève infecté va rejeter environ
0,5m3 d’air par heure.
S’il parle beaucoup ou qu’il chante,
les valeurs seront plus élevées,
jusqu’à 1m3 d’air rejeté par heure.
On va noter Q ce débit d’air expiré.
Maintenant la question c’est: combien il
y a de virus dans cet air expiré?
Alors c’est assez difficile à savoir,
et je vais prendre une valeur
pour les besoins de la cause, je reviendrai
dessus tout à l’heure, vous verrez.
On va dire qu’il y 1000 copies
du virus par m3 d’air expiré.
Évidemment il faut bien avoir en tête que
ces copies du virus ne sont pas
à l’air libre, elles sont dans
les micro-gouttelettes, les aérosols,
mais notre hypothèse c’est que dans tous
les aérosols
contenus dans 1m3 d’air expiré,
ça fait 1000 exemplaires du virus.
On va noter ça Cv, la concentration en virus
dans l’air expiré.
Après il y a un truc super important:
le masque.
S’il est bien mis, il va absorber
une bonne partie des gouttelettes,
donc des exemplaires du virus.
Un masque chirurgical a une efficacité
d’environ 90%,
c’est-à-dire que ce ne sont que 10%
des virus qui passent,
on va noter f cette fraction, donc 0,1.
Au passage vous noterez deux choses:
premièrement c’est important que ce soit
un masque et pas une visière.
Une visière ça peut capturer les grosses
gouttelettes
qui sont projetées quand on éternue,
mais les aérosols en suspension ils ne sont
pas arrêtés par la visière.
L’autre chose c’est que le masque doit
être bien porté, y compris sur le nez.
On parle de gouttelettes contenues
dans la respiration,
la respiration c’est beaucoup par le nez,
donc si le masque est sous le nez,
tout cet air contaminé va sortir
sans problème.
Donc pour nos élèves, on peut supposer
que le masque n’est pas tout le temps
porté de façon parfaite, et qu’au total
ce sont 15% des virus passent,
donc f=0,15.
Si je fais le produit de ces 3 quantités:
0,5m3/h, 1000 virus par m3 et 15% des virus
qui passent, j’obtiens
la quantité de virus rejetés dans l’air
ambiant par notre malade à chaque heure.
Ici Q fois f fois Cv, ça fait environ 75
virus expirés par heure.
Ensuite on doit tenir compte du fait que les
micro-gouttelettes
qui contiennent les virus, une fois rejetées,
elles vont assez vite diffuser
dans toute la pièce.
Donc mes 75 virus vont se retrouver dilués
dans l’ensemble du volume de la salle.
Si la salle de classe fait 50m2 et
qu'elle a 3m de hauteur sous plafond,
ces 75 virus seront dilués dans un volume
V de 150m3 d’air.
Donc la concentration moyenne une fois
dilués, ça va être 0,5 virus par m3.
Ça parait pas beaucoup.
Sauf que souvenez vous, ça c’est ce qui
est ajouté dans l’air à chaque heure.
Donc en théorie la concentration en virus
dans l’air ambiant devrait
augmenter en continu: 0,5 1 1,5 2 etc.
heure après heure.
Enfin ça ce serait si la salle de classe
était un bocal parfaitement étanche,
heureusement une pièce n’est jamais étanche,
il y a des bouches d’aérations,
peut-être même une ventilation mécanique
qui extrait l’air et le rejette à l’extérieur
et probablement qu’on aère de temps en temps
en ouvrant les fenêtres.
Il y a plusieurs moyens de quantifier tous
ces phénomènes, une façon simple,
c’est de regarder le taux de renouvellement
de l’air de la pièce:
combien de fois l’air de la pièce
est renouvelé à chaque heure.
Supposons qu’il faille deux heures pour
tout renouveler,
ça veut dire que le taux de renouvellement
est de 0,5 fois par heure.
On va noter ça lambda.
En gros ça veut dire que chaque heure,
les virus rejetés
ne se diluent pas dans 150m3 d’air frais,
mais dans 0,5 fois cette valeur.
En faisant bien le calcul on peut montrer
qu’entre ce qui est rejeté par le malade
et ce qui est renouvelé, la concentration
de virus dans l’air ambiant
va atteindre un équilibre qui est égal
à Q x f x Cv divisé par lambda V.
Avec les chiffres qu’on a choisit, ça nous
met à 1 virus par m3.
Alors est-ce que c’est beaucoup
1 virus par m3?
Eh bien maintenant on va essayer d’estimer
combien d’infections ça va causer.
Mettons nous à la place d’un autre élève
situé ailleurs dans la classe.
Lui il va aussi respirer l’air ambiant,
et il va inspirer et expirer
au même rythme que ce qu’on supposé
tout à l’heure: un taux Q de 0,5 m3/h.
Si l’élève contagieux reste disons 3 jours
en classe avant d’être testé et isolé,
ça veut dire qu’à 7h de cours par jour,
notre élève sain va être exposé
au virus ambiant pendant une vingtaine
d’heures au total.
On va noter "tau" ce temps d’exposition.
Une vingtaine d’heures à 0,5m3 par heure,
ça fait 10m3 d’air inhalé.
Si on multiplie ça par la concentration
en virus dans l’air ambiant,
il y a un virus par m3, donc ça fait
10 exemplaires du virus
qui seront inhalés par cet élève
sur les 3 jours d’exposition.
Sauf qu’on a oublié un truc, le masque!
Oui, ça marche aussi dans ce sens là,
le masque va filtrer 90% des virus entrants,
donc seulement un seul sur les 10 va passer,
ça ne fait plus qu’un seul virus inhalé.
Je vous mets la formule complète ici de tous
nos calculs,
le nombre de virus inhalés au total
ç'est: tau Q² f² Cv divisé par lambda V.
Un virus inhalé donc, mais est-ce que c’est
grave?
Est-ce que ça suffit à choper le COVID?
Eh bien probablement pas!
A chaque virus, il y a une certaine
probabilité "p" qu’il vous infecte vraiment.
Combien vaut cette probabilité?
On va dire 10%: seulement un risque sur 10
à chaque exemplaire du virus.
Et on rediscutera ça tout à l’heure.
On va donc multiplier notre formule par p,
et ça va nous donner notre probabilité
d’être infecté.
Notre pauvre élève qui a inhalé
en moyenne 1 virus
au cours de ses 20 heures d’exposition,
il n’a que 10% de chance de tomber malade.
Franchement ça va!
Ça va, sauf qu’ils sont 30 dans la classe,
à être tout autant exposés à ce mode de
contamination,
donc si chaque élève à 10% de chance,
on est à peu près certains
de se récupérer un, voire plusieurs cas.
En gros pour simplifier, on peut multiplier
notre formule par N,
N: le nombre de personnes présentes.
Et cette grosse formule, ça donne en gros
la probabilité
qu’il y ait une transmission du virus.
Et je vous rappelle, même s’il n’y a qu’une
transmission, en fait c’est beaucoup.
Si chaque malade le transmet
à plus d’une personne,
le nombre de reproduction, le fameux "R0"
va être supérieur à 1,
et donc l’épidémie va continuer
de façon exponentielle.
Ce qu’on veut, c’est amener ça
en-dessous de 1.
On veut en moyenne moins d’une transmission
par malade.
Et comme là on raisonne juste sur le temps
passé en classe,
on aimerait bien amener ce chiffre
vraiment en dessous de 1.
Alors pour ça observons ensemble
cette formule,
elle nous dit des choses intéressantes
surla transmission par voie d’aérosols.
Premièrement, c’est proportionnel
au temps d’exposition cumulé tau,
c’est assez logique, si on reste deux fois
plus longtemps, le risque double.
Ensuite le coefficient de filtration f
apparait au carré,
eh oui il y a un double effet des masques,
ils limitent les virus expirés par le porteur,
et ceux inhalés par le receveur.
Un masque bien porté, c’est seulement 10%
seulement de virus qui passent à chaque fois,
donc ça réduit au total la transmission
d’un facteur 100.
L’effet du masque est énorme.
Au dénominateur, on voit qu’on a le volume
de la pièce
et le taux de renouvellement de l’air.
Plus la pièce est grande et plus
l’air est renouvelé,
moins on prend de risques, c’est logique,
mais c’est bien de le voir.
Et puis ici il nous reste deux termes dont
je vous ai promis qu’on reviendrait dessus.
La concentration en virus
dans l’air expiré: Cv,
et la probabilité de contamination p
quand on inhale une copie du virus.
Je vous ai donné des valeurs,
qui sont crédibles,
mais sur lesquelles on a en fait
une grande incertitude.
C’est assez dur de savoir ça.
Alors est-ce que ça discrédite
toute l’analyse?
Eh bien non, car en fait ce qui compte,
vous voyez:
c’est le produit de ces deux quantités.
1000 virus par m3 expiré, et 10%
de probabilité de contamination,
c’est la même chose que 10 000 virus par m3
et 1% de probabilité.
Imaginez que ce soit 10%, cette probabilité,
ça veut dire qu’il faut en moyenne
une exposition à 10 copies du virus pour
être contaminés,
donc 1000 virus par m3, c’est 100 fois
cette quantité, cette "dose",
cette dose on va appeler ça:
un quantum d’infection.
Je dis "quantum" mais rien à voir
avec la mécanique quantique,
c’est juste la quantité typique
qu’il faut pour être infecté.
Et nos 1 000 virus par m3, représentent
donc 100 quantum d’infection par m3.
Et si ça avait été 10 000 virus avec
une probabilité de 1%,
ça aurait été la même chose ça aurait fait
aussi 100 quantum d’infection par m3.
Donc dans notre analyse, on va oublier la
concentration en virus
et la probabilité d’infection,
on va remplacer par le produit des deux,
la concentration en quantum d’infection,
on va la noter Cq, et pourquoi c’est mieux?
Parce que c’est quelque chose qu’on peut
plus facilement estimer.
Martin Bazant et John Bush, les deux
physiciens qui ont écrit l’article,
ont pris les données de divers événements
de contamination,
et ils ont pu estimer des valeurs moyennes
pour la concentration en quantum d’infection
émis par un malade.
La valeur typique qu’ils ont obtenu pour
une activité normale,
c’est d’environ 70 quantum
par m3 d’air expiré.
Mais pour le cas de la chorale,
où les gens chantaient,
la valeur serait plus proche
de 900 quantum par m3.
On imagine volontiers que quand on chante
fort, on expulse plus de gouttelettes,
qui viennent peut-être de régions
différentes des poumons,
et que ça fasse augmenter de beaucoup
la concentration
en quantum d’infection de l’air expiré.
Évidemment cette estimation va dépendre de
tout un tas de facteurs:
l’état de symptôme du malade, la population
cible et aussi bien sûr, la souche du virus.
Si certains variants, comme le fameux variant
anglais, sont plus contagieux,
cela va se traduire par des concentrations
en quantum plus élevées.
Notez qu’on ne sait pas forcément si avec
le variant anglais les gouttelettes d’aérosol
sont plus concentrées en virus, ou bien si
c’est la probabilité d’infection
associée à un exemplaire du virus
qui est plus élevée,
mais l’effet sur la concentration en quantum
d’infection est le même,
ça va l’augmenter peut-être de 50%.
Dans tous les cas, vous voyez que ma valeur
de 100 quantum par m3
était assez raisonnable, on n’a pas
de valeur super précise,
mais c’est essentiellement le seul paramètre
de l’analyse
sur lequel on ait une incertitude.
En prenant une bonne marge de sécurité
ça peut nous permettre d’avancer
dans le raisonnement.
Alors revenons à notre formule, on a dit
qu’on voulait limiter
la reproduction du virus, et donc faire
descendre cette valeur assez en dessous de 1.
Pour être large avec nos incertitudes,
on va dire qu’on se fixe
un seuil de tolérance à 10%.,
on va le noter epsilon et donc voilà
ce qu’on veut:
tout ça inférieur à epsilon.
Qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire pour respecter
ce seuil?
On peut se poser la question
pour chaque situation
où on réunit des personnes
dans une même pièce.
Là je vais regarder avec les caractéristiques
que j’ai donné pour la salle de classe.
Premièrement on peut limiter le nombre de
personnes présentes N
et le temps d’exposition tau.
De ce point de vue, la pratique de la
demi-jauge va évidemment dans le bon sens.
Autre truc essentiel, il faut bien porter
le masque,
je rappelle que le facteur f
qui a un effet au carré.
Il faut aussi éviter les activités comme
le chant ou le sport
qui augmentent le débit de respiration Q.
Pour le sport ça peut faire un facteur 10
sur le débit, mis au carré ça fait 100.
Donc le sport en intérieur et pire,
sans masque, c’est NON!
Le volume de la pièce V, a priori
on ne peut pas trop le changer.
Mais il nous reste lambda, le taux
de renouvellement de l’air.
Dans mon exemple, j’avais été
assez pessimiste,
j’avais pris 0,5: un renouvellement
toutes les 2 heures
C’est une valeur typique pour des locaux
résidentiels,
mais en local collectif, avec un bon système
de ventilation
ou une aération périodique,
on peut faire beaucoup mieux.
On peut multiplier cette valeur par 5 voire
10, et donc diminuer d’autant le risque.
Si on a la main sur un système de ventilation
mécanique,
un repère typique est d’imposer un débit
de ventilation
d’environ 30m3 par heure et par personne.
Avec mes 30 élèves ça fait 900 m3 par heure,
donc mes 150 m3 de salle de classe seront
renouvelés 6 fois par heure.
6 fois pour lambda au lieu de 0,5
j’ai diminué mon risque d’un facteur 12.
Ça c’est bien s’il y a une ventilation
mécanique dont on contrôle le débit,
mais il est vraisemblable que dans beaucoup
de situations ce ne soit pas le cas.
Alors comment on fait pour déjà estimer
ce fameux lambda,
et faire en sorte d’atteindre des valeurs
assez hautes?
Eh bien une solution pour traiter
ce problème,
c’est de mesurer le taux de CO2
dans la salle.
[jingle]
Eh oui le CO2 ça marche presque comme les
virus,
on en rejette une quantité à peu près
déterminée à chaque heure,
et donc surveiller la concentration en CO2
nous indique comment évoluerait
la concentration en virus
dans l’hypothèse où il y ait un malade
dans la pièce.
Voyons ça en chiffres: les élèves respirent
0,5m3 d’air par heure,
et l’air expiré contient environ 4% de CO2,
on va noter "k" cette fraction,
et ça fait environ 20L de CO2 émis
chaque heure, pour chaque élève.
Comme pour le virus, le CO2 va s’accumuler
et sa concentration augmenter,
mais comme pour le virus, ce taux est dilué
par le renouvellement de l’air.
On a le même genre de raisonnement et
à l’équilibre
le taux moyen est égal à Q k fois N
(le nombre d’élèves) , divisé par lambda V.
Alors attention ça n’est pas
le vrai taux moyen,
c’est ce qui est ajouté en plus du taux
de base de l’air extérieur.
Si vous avez 30 élèves dans 150m3, que vous
avez un lambda de 6,
ça va vous faire environ 0.065%
de CO2 en plus.
Le CO2 souvent on compte pas en %
mais plutôt en ppm, parties par millions,
ça fait 650ppm, à ajouter au taux
de base de l’air extérieur qui est 400ppm,
ça fait un peu plus que 1 000ppm au total.
Avec un taux de renouvellement plus faible,
vous auriez des valeurs plus élevées,
mais on peut prendre le problème à l’envers:
si vous voulez tenir l’objectif
de renouvellement de lambda égal à 6,
avec le nombre d’élèves et le volume
de pièce que j’ai choisi,
il faut donc viser 1 000ppm de CO2
en moyenne, pas plus.
D'ailleurs, pour ceux qui n'ont pas peur
des formules,
on peut combiner l'estimation de surplus
de CO2 avec notre objectif
sur la probabilité de transmission
pour traduire le tout
en un objectif sur le surplus de CO2.
Ça donne une formule assez élégante
qui ne dépend plus des caractéristiques
de la pièce.
Avec des valeurs un peu plus conservatrices
on va trouver un objectif
de surplus de CO2 moyen d'environ 200ppm,
ajouter les 400ppm de l'atmosphère,
ça fait plutôt un objectif total moyen
de 600ppm.
Une façon de le faire, c’est de mesurer
le taux de CO2 en direct,
et d’ouvrir en grand les fenêtres
régulièrement pendant quelques minutes,
pour revenir au niveau de base de 400ppm,
et osciller comme ça autour
de votre objectif.
Dans un article paru dans le numéro
de Décembre 2020 de "Pour la science",
Jean-Michel Courty Édouard Kierlik
et Benoît Semin
ont rapporté des mesures que Jean-Michel
a faites dans son bureau,
où on voit qu’en quelques minutes d’ouverture
des fenêtres
on retombe presque au taux de base.
Le temps nécessaire va dépendre évidemment
du vent,
e la géométrie de la pièce, des fenêtres etc.
mais ça donne l’idée.
En conclusion, en mesurant le taux de CO2
dans une salle de classe,
ou n’importe quelle pièce où on réunit
plusieurs personnes pendant un certain temps,
on peut utiliser les formules dont on a parlé
pour se fixer des objectifs
permettant une dilution qui assurera
la limitation des risques de transmission.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, j’espère
que cette petite analyse vous permettra
d’ajouter l’aération à votre arsenal
de gestes barrière.
C’est simple, pas cher, et avec les beaux
jours qui reviennent,
ça devient forcément
de plus en plus possible.
Un point à mentionner c’est que l’article
dont je vous ai parlé a fait un peu de bruit
aux États-Unis, mais il a été très mal
repris par une partie de la presse
et des réseaux sociaux, qui ont dit
que ça montrait
que la distance physique ne servait à rien,
voire carrément que les masques
étaient inutiles.
Évidemment c’est pas ça du tout, et j’espère
avoir fait passer les messages importants.
Je vous mets en description le lien
vers l’article, vous verrez
que j’ai essayé d’utiliser dans mes formules
des notations proches des leurs,
donc si ça vous intéresse, vous devriez
pouvoir vous y retrouver.
Concernant les mesure de CO2, vous pouvez
notamment consulter le site "projetCO2.fr"
qui donne des conseils sur comment procéder,
quels capteurs utiliser, etc.
il y a plein d’infos super utiles
dont je n'ai pas parlé.
Vous l’aurez remarqué, depuis le début
de cette pandémie,
j’ai assez soigneusement évité les sujets
"covid" sur la chaine,
principalement parce que ça n’est
pas exactement mon domaine de compétence.
Là j’ai fait une exception parce que c’était
plus mon rayon.
J’espère que ça vous a plu.
Pour les autres sujets covid,
je vous mets en description
des liens vers des vulgarisatrices
et vulgarisateurs spécialisés
qui traitent le sujet de façon régulière
et avec sérieux.
Comme toujours abonnez vous, la cloche,
tout ça,
partagez cette vidéo aux élèves,
aux enseignants
qui ne seraient pas encore sensibilisés
à ces questions,
et nous on se retrouve très vite
pour d’autres vidéos, à bientôt.
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -